c'est que tu fumes autant sur cigarette
à la main ce soir pourquoi tu fais
autant c'est marrant tu jamais sortis
directement cette phrase quand on sert
montrer ça a été odieuse dont tu
déconnes ou quoi jeter les drogués comme
nous quoi attend on la refait pourquoi
tu fumes autant
un moment sur cigarette à la main ce
soir
je voulais mourir
mais trop agressive je suis pas grisée
pour gilles m j'aime ici c'est pagis ou
compris en fait vous n'êtes pas épilée
c'est dégueulasse
les autres il faut croire qu'on s'en va
on s'en fout des autres
alors un seul des vastes hirvo 10 rue de
la soul réaliste soriano jam in marines
mais h film
on se bat par les allemands ouais bah je
m'en tape
j'habite pas loin
là
je connais pas les quartiers
et voilà mademoiselle bassel tu veux je
vais à la fnac
demain bah ouais j'aime bien les dvd
pourquoi pas salut c'est chouette
pouvoir se dire les choses maintenant
moi j'aime bien on voit que l'on vous
jusqu'au bout moi aussi j'aime bien
là
mais
j'étais moi aussi